I now am using AI as a thinking partner
I'm literally asking a bunch of AI tools
questions like why is long hair coming
in why are caps back versus not you know
why are people consuming this beverage
and so I think for the creative class
they they default into thinking AI is
going to take away my job instead of
realizing ai's about to become your
thinking partner you're a celebrate
entrepreneur a major advocate for the
Esports and web3 gaming space and you've
also started your own web free platform
like I mentioned at the beginning the
friends so for those people in the
audience that don't know about v-friends
can you just break that down for us and
just tell us a bit about that you know
I'm 47 years old I was born in the
Soviet Union I came to the United States
when I was three and I grew up in the
80s where an enormous amount of
intellectual property was created on
television and through toys so
Transformers and Care Bears and My
Little Pony and Strawberry Shortcake and
GI Joe and so I've been very affected by
pop culture my whole life and
um 14 years ago I started a marketing
company vaynermedia but really what it
was actually looking to do was build a
Global Communications framework that
would allow me to accelerate extracting
attention to whatever I wanted to do
my main point was in the back half of
that mission was to really create a new
form of private Equity when I think
about private Equity
um
those organizations are very good at
buying businesses in a smart way and
cutting costs and running a more
efficient business what I was always
fascinated by and have done in my entire
career has created hyper growth so I
wanted to create a platform an operating
system to create hyper growth my plan
was to buy an established historic
intellectual property that I grew up
with Casper the Friendly Ghost Gumby
Scooby-Doo wherever my professional
career took me and my financial
capabilities I was going to go and buy
one when I started seeing what was
happening in web 3 it became very
obvious to me that's similar to after
school television or video games like
with Mario and Zelda or other formats
like books we've seen in history that
this was a platform to create
intellectual property so be friends in
its simplest form is the in my view a
basis of almost 300 characters that kind
of takes the essence of Sesame Street
and Pokemon and brings them together so
a very high focus on being competitive
uh like Pokemon but a very strong
message of Civility and kindness empathy
that comes from Jim Henson's world so I
launched that a couple years ago and I'm
pretty excited about it it's very early
I'm only two years into the journey but
it's um it's something I planned on
building in a very significant way yeah
you say you're only teasing to the
journey but from what I can see well I
can see it's very successful in the
early stages it's amazing for you for me
for 40 years I've been looking at
trading cards and comic books and movies
and television and marketing and so it's
it's it's I've had a lot of practice in
it yeah yeah um and I'm enjoying it yeah
I love that little stroll down memory
lane as well make me feel a bit old
mentioning all those um
well you know what's fun though and it's
good timing because back to films and
back to video games I'm sure it's very
much on everyone's radar how well the
Super Mario movie is doing right now
commercially you know for me gaming you
know obviously it's a big week for me
um I'm a part owner of version one with
the will family that owns the Minnesota
Vikings and in the US so obviously we
are super proud of the win we had here
in rocket league and so I've been in
gaming for a long time Vayner Sports is
a sports agency uh that I own that
represents a bunch of athletes including
clicks and Booga who are very prominent
Gamers so this is a space that I've
spent a lot of time paying attention to
and been involved in it's interesting to
hear what Michael's speaking about and
kind of the way I'm thinking about
intellectual property we haven't because
we're only 24 months in we're very early
on the be friends IP but to me if I'm
able to accomplish what I'm trying to
achieve it's inconceivable to me that I
can do that without having a major win
in the gaming space and so I spend a lot
of time paying attention to it because
if you look at again the Mario's the
zeldas
um the things of that nature plus more
modern things like Angry Birds
intellectual property being built on the
foundation of gaming is is very clear
and obvious and the affinity and the
emotion and the attachment to those
characters through this format yeah very
similar to sports very similar to film
is very evident in human behavior and
something I spend a lot of time on yeah
yeah so an area that I want to touch on
I think we can't have this conversation
without the acronym nft yes and you are
one of the most quite prolific voice in
this space yes what are your thoughts on
the viability of nfts in the future
economy is there a future for this this
method this form of course where nft
sits right now for most people in this
audience and around the world world is
where the internet sat in 2000. if you
remember in 2000 all the internet
companies were wildly overvalued in
public markets because the hype of the
internet engulfed us pets.com was worth
eight billion dollars with no Revenue
obviously all those projects failed and
a lot of people wrote many articles in
2000 is the internet of fad the web's a
fad from Hollywood to Wall Street
but the technology was too big the same
thing's happening right now in nfts the
last two years there was way too much
greed way too much not realness and what
happened was the brand itself is being
recorrected right now and being reset
but anybody here that is not paying
attention very deeply to what's
happening with blockchain blockchain
technology especially if you're in the
gaming space is making a humongous
mistake of opportunity I think over the
next decade when you think about what
ownership means think about all the
games here that make remarkable revenue
on the digital assets being sold in a
closed ecosystem it's a closed ecosystem
when you start understanding the
Dynamics of how that plays in an open
ecosystem like the blockchain and how
that's transferable and what that means
to The Gamers and what they are able to
amass within games you're trading your
FIFA points for a Call of Duty Point
think about the kid that goes from mind
share and Roblox to FIFA to Call of Duty
and you're able to own those digital
assets I I'm positive that next World
2030 is talking about blockchains and
nfts about 50 to 70 percent of the
panels today because of the greed of the
last year or two in nft land everyone's
putting it on the side yeah much like
internet
2001-2-345 that was the time to actually
build and I think the one to two percent
in this audience that are thoughtful and
understand their history of technology
and understand pattern recognition will
Deep dive deeper into web 3 and I think
it's an inevitable outcome yeah yeah
it's interesting because you know the
kind of the way nfts blew up and now
there's a bit of a stigma attached to it
and I don't think worse people really
truly understand the power of blockchain
the power of this technology to
basically give back the the ownership to
to Gamers to users and not putting it in
the power that happened with nfts is
people forget that only one percent of
things work right everybody thought
every nft project was going to work only
one percent of films become iconic only
one percent of iPhone apps become
successful only one percent of art or
trading cards or Collectibles become the
top and so what happened was it was such
a new technology everybody thought all
of it was going to work when in reality
only one percent of a genre can ever
reach the levels that people anticipated
so it's cliche human behavior the breed
took over now we reset but the macro
technology of decentralized servers will
be one of the most significant things
that impacts uh everybody in the world
and when you think about the context of
a country like this that is so Dynamic
moving so so much faster than the rest
of the world I I do think it's a missed
opportunity for people not to take
things like blockchain and Ai and all
the emerging technology serious because
that's where all the opportunity lies in
the next half decade yeah do you think
they because you know emerging
Technologies there's this inherent fear
wherever big companies small companies
big players little players just to to
get involved in that space because it's
it's new territory it's Uncharted
Territory yes that's why it's so
lucrative when you're good at it
Michael Michael please educate everybody
here how Hollywood looked at the
internet in the late 90s early 2000s
well
um I was never computer savvy so
um how did they look at it
um
I thought it was pretty groundbreaking
it was groundbreaking definitely I mean
I remember the Apple thing with little
discs right
um but uh
and then it's used for piracy quite a
bit
um you know the music industry the film
industry Bill Gates was at the top of
the technology sphere yeah in the mid
90s and completely poo pooed the
internet of having any viability yes so
I think the biggest thing for everybody
in this room is to understand that the
incumbents of any technology are often
not financially incentivized to support
the new technologies because their money
is at risk right yeah and that is always
where the opportunity is based on
consumer Behavior not based on your
pockets and so there will be many
decisions made by entities governments
entrepreneurs Enterprises that are
always wrong because they are worried
about their short-term finances instead
of how humans are actually interacting
yeah just ignoring all the signs it's
like right there come go this way and
it's like well no it's it's another
version of the greed that screwed up the
nft brand in the short term people are
worried about the ROI of their money
tomorrow yes and they dismiss what
consumers are doing the consumer
Behavior interacting with the blockchain
and AI today today is at the highest
level it's ever been yeah and so again I
think people are incredibly uh
short-term thinking uh transactional and
that is where all the opportunity always
sits yeah yeah I don't know it'll be
really interesting in the same vein that
we can look back at the early 2000s you
read these articles well the Internet
it's fad that's never going to take off
and it'll be interesting the next 15 to
20 years where we're going to be at and
how people reacted to blockchain in web
3. do you remember this little thing
there are many people in this audience
and around the world that said they
would never use this because the
Blackberry had buttons on it and they
needed their buttons
humans are very good at saying no to new
technology what all of us need to do
especially Dynamic places like this is
you must be in the business of maybe you
must be in the business of maybe and you
must spend your 10 or 20 hours there are
plenty of people in this audience right
now that have profound opinions on AI
and nfts and have never played with it
yeah that is the issue at hand in the
world in technology most people are not
practitioners they're headline readers
yes that is very very true and just my
final question to you you know there's
obviously a current a very obvious
current dip in nfts at the moment I
think I know your answer but would you
say this is just temporary is a thing is
going to change I think it's no I think
it's permanent for the 99 of projects
that stink
the the macro is established nfts will
be here for the rest of our lives but
remember a non-fungible token is the
slang term we know it today as a digital
collectible what it really is is far
bigger than that the majority people in
this room will have contracts of buying
homes doing Deeds Insurance like
day-to-day things will be done in the
form of an nft because it's a more
secure contract than anything that sits
on Earth yes and so no I think the brand
will recover with better usage but no I
think this is the way it was always
supposed to be 99.9 percent of
footballers rookie cards are worthless
his isn't because he was great yeah
right and so the problem is 99 of like
that one Garrett that's good thank you
99 of nft projects
it's not going to get any better because
the Creator the creative the operator is
not capable of creating demand and
Affinity but for the one percent it will
be like writing a Harry Potter book
worked out writing a bad book did not
work out and I think that's where people
got it confused they kind of lumped the
whole genre together that's like saying
gaming does or doesn't work the amount
of games that come out every year are
profound the far majority of them don't
get to come to things like this and so I
think early Technologies get lumped as a
genre and they're misunderstood and I
think that's where we are right now yeah
so there's a massive education that
needs to happen right in a minute yeah
absolutely so when I move on to the just
you know just talk briefly about the
Cinematic influence on video games we've
seen AAA games have huge budget you know
it's that rival big Hollywood
Productions if not more so Michael what
Hollywood Trends have you seen that are
influencing or having you know a major
effect on enhancing storytelling when it
comes to gaming with the accent excuse
me oh sorry
um what what trends or Hollywood Trends
what things have you been seeing and
that are influencing or having an effect
on gaming or the the essence of
Storytelling and gaming well like I was
saying I mean I I really do think
there's
games can Aspire with movie people
cinematic people with the artists and
whatnot to to to to try to create
together I think you can make the
stronger game you know you can make a a
the the seek the dirty secret when your
movie director is it's time time is your
enemy and you have two hours and when
you're cutting a movie it starts at
three or four and you're cutting it down
and then all of a sudden I carry the
sheet around oh my God we got two
seconds today we took out four seconds
today three seconds it it really matters
whereas a game you can have a much more
involving story and the the the the I
think it's interesting that's different
than a movie uh you can have the the the
audience and participant help
like create the game help you to to to
to help the franchise grow to to uh they
could be participants in the
storytelling uh which is kind of a a I
think a great thing
um it's an exciting thing but
um listen there's been a lot of
successful Movie game uh things uh but
uh you know yeah yeah that's just I just
want to rewind back a little bit what
I'm saying ultimately is if they
participate more together yeah yeah yeah
I just want to go back to I just
remembered that we had a quick chat
backstage I want to hear your opinion on
NF the nft space on nfts yeah
I'm in the 99 now
it makes a lot of sense what he's saying
it really does
um so he's opened my eyes you know but
that's not the education that I was
talking about it's it's
what about hacking people getting all
your stuff stolen I think are people
worried about that of course they are
but to remind everybody
just to remind everybody I think history
is something people struggle with there
used to be a time where humans lived on
earth without banks
that's real life it was a long long time
ago but it was existence the you know
people used to be scared to put their
credit card into a computer
there are many people in this audience
that remember credit cards being stolen
on the Internet it's just time just like
in your world time is a thing this is a
brand new technology and so I think we
cars are better today than they were a
hundred years ago planes are better
today than they were phones are better
today than they were 25 years ago so
what about those things they will be
resolved yeah with time
and it's you know interesting that you
mentioned hacking and kind of I guess
security elements but that is the beauty
of blockchain and the beauty of things
like nfts it's this impenetrable
technology that's a lot more secure a
lot safer but it's a perception that
people have no no yeah no no that's what
you've got to change it's that's right
it is safer the problem is it's you're
the custodial when your money is stolen
through a fake credit card transaction
you call the bank and they fix it when
you were the person that owns the keys
to your assets on the blockchain if you
make a mistake which is what he's
referring to it's gone I lose every
password so that's a problem
so anyway
it's just early okay interesting stuff
so I want to talk about now about the
the kind of business and marketing of
Esports so um diving into the the
business side of Esports what are your
uh Gareth what your strategies or for
promoting teams engaging fans and
attracting sponsors from a business and
celebrity perspective if you've got any
thoughts on that I just I think it's
just like saying everything changes with
time I think
I think you look back to when I first
started you're on just the front cover
of a magazine that you could only see it
when you went into a shop yeah now you
can post something for example on my
social media they can straight away go
to 50 100 million people within the
space of a second so
yeah things have changed I think in
terms of gaming now
is so accessible to everybody
um on streaming platforms on like say
social media platforms everything's
really accessible quick and it's just
change with the time and I think
yeah I think it's it's become a lot
easier to Market things and to promote
things now than it ever has been because
you don't have to travel to places you
can literally
do what you need to do where you are
click a button upload it and it
potentially goes to the world so um yeah
I think it's how you get over the
Clutter yeah yeah and have you seen I
guess any
any interesting strategies or kind of
points of attack from other companies in
the Esports space so you thought well
it's really interesting how they're
trying to get people's attention and
Garner that attention from people or
Recruit new new people yeah I think it's
it's just the way you potentially run
your team the content that you kind of
create
you have obviously a lot of YouTubers
content creators now that can create a
different kind of atmosphere around a
team they can make it more fun more
serious more
kind of what Avenue you would like to
take and um
like I said it's just it's so easy to
kind of Market that and get it out to
everybody to kind of support that team
or get involved with that team it's
really easy to kind of go down that
space these days and I think it's been
really fascinating just just watching
that trajectory as well like you said
back in the day you know you're on the
front of a magazine that's it and now
there's just so multifaceted there's so
many Avenues so many ways to reach out
to celebrities and reach out to fans and
it really is such an exciting time isn't
it and it's only going to grow and get
better yeah that's that's the the crazy
thing that you never you always get to a
point you think how can this get better
and some clever mind yeah like these
guys in the world that have such amazing
talent and such Vision that they create
different Avenues to make things even
better and yeah I think that's what
makes
the individual more exciting than for
example AI which is a bit more
straightforward yeah yeah what's
interesting that you just mentioned AIS
over the last 10 minutes of this
discussion I want to talk about
artificial intelligence and I think we
can't talk about gaming Esports it's
Hollywood we can't talk about that
without AI infiltrating because you know
it's a massive talking point at the
moment
um so with the rapid advancement of AI
you know playing a greater role in the
entertainment industry and I'd like to
discuss you know the implications on AI
and storytelling and business and what
role you see it playing I'm going to
just throw that out to anyone if anyone
wants to take that
I'm spending some serious time in this
space I think again similar to the
blockchain similar to the internet in
the past there's a lot of opinions and a
lot of Curiosities there's a ton of fear
yes um there's a smaller group of
optimism and and looking to go on the
offense here's what I can promise you
one
it's not going to go away
so if you're going to put your head in
the sand and hope it goes away it's it's
not AI is going to be a humongous
implication as a technology for everyone
in this room I think number two like
most technologies that are big it's
going to save us a lot of time yes
there's a lot of things that a lot of
people do here today spend a lot of
money on today on humans or
infrastructure Hardware software that AI
implications are going to make
dramatically more efficient there's also
a lot of creative ways to work with it
so for me I spend most of my time
thinking about human behavior pop Trends
why people are wearing their hair the
way they are or why they wear hats or
stickers all that stuff I now am using
AI as a thinking partner I'm literally
asking a bunch of AI tools questions
like why is long hair coming in why are
caps back versus not you know why are
people consuming this beverage and so I
think for the creative class they they
default into thinking a is going to take
away my job instead of realizing AI is
about to become your thinking partner
you're going to have curiosity the same
way that many people here use a search
engine
to expand on something they're thinking
through that is Child's Play compared to
what AI Bots are going to be able to do
and AI machine learning infrastructures
are going to be able to do so I think
for the creative class for this industry
things are going to be produced quicker
because of the speed and and I think
people are going to come up with bigger
and more exciting ideas because the
technology is going to guide them in the
same way that a search engine was better
than going to the library and looking it
up on the encyclopedia it made it faster
it made it quicker it made it more
Dynamic I think those are two things
that are going to be very clear in this
industry yes
no I I mean just as a creative person
um I saw some a writer wrote and typed
in an image the Ridley Scott image a
Michael Bay image a Tony Scott image and
I saw it I said where did you get that
and because I could recognize some stuff
that my team had done
what I realized is it was cool but AI
has no soul okay AI is just mathematics
okay and Mathematics does not have a
soul so I'm not worried about it I'm
worried for my music friends but AI
can't predict the shot that I'm going to
create I always create new stuff in my
films they can they can't they're not me
um but I am very worried first of all
that it's going to make people lazy it
could be a tool yes I hear it from
medicine it's great but I'm very worried
that it could be used for nefarious
reasons we were just talking about deep
fakes back there there's all this news
about and they can take three four
seconds of your voice they've got enough
pictures of you from magazines and
whatever and they can make you say
whatever you want and that's going to be
a big problem pretty soon you're not
going to know what to believe in the
world but the worst thing I'm worried
about because the nefarious of where
Humanity sometimes goes
I was in a room
where the U.S military it's a special
room it's where the two men hold the two
keys that can end the world now that's a
very scary room to be in okay but they
have communication to Russia of all
different types of communication and
four times in our lifetime we've had
fake launches almost launches that could
end Humanity so that's where I worry
about it that's that's just me being a
movie director okay we always do end of
the world kind of scenarios okay
um it's a good movie fun to think but
I'm worried about the nefarious things
that AI can can yeah and I think at the
moment there's there's not enough
regulation there's not enough kind of
understanding of it and I think to to
your point Gary if it's used kind of to
complement things or to work side by
side it's about attention I think
Michael's point is remarkably right I
also remind everybody that there used to
be a world without atomic bombs and then
technology created them and yet here we
are 70 years later I think it's very
easy to default into fear I think it's
actually the biggest issue in the world
I think fear is weaponized I think fear
is at scale or could be a cool movie too
yes for sure and I'm very empathetic to
it and I think deep fake will be
enormously a big issue in the world I
fully agree with that but I also know
back to my earlier point this is where
Technologies like the blockchain are
better than Technologies like the
internet with the blockchain when I
upload my videos about me on the
blockchain it's going to be very
verifiable that it was me what I think
it's one big game of cat and mouse right
to Michael's Point there's going to be
the bad guys and there's gonna be the
good guys and there's always those
technology advances so to Michael's
point today the videos that I see on in
the world I believe them yes in a decade
I will have to do another thing to make
sure they're real because of this new
technology but again we've always
invented things that could be abused or
not abused the internet is used for good
the internet is used for bad credit
cards are used for good and so I I just
think that we There's an opportunity to
not spend all of our time dwelling on
what is going to go wrong and I think
it's important for people that have
practical optimism to look at these
tools and figure out what's going to go
well yeah Gary's a very common uh source
of this panel right now
even worrying about AI taking over
creative roles and copying the likeness
of celebrities and deep faces the
tractor was invented and took does
everybody understand that 80 of the
world used to work on farms around the
world and the tractor was invented and
people said this is going to take away
jobs it created jobs it allowed us to
leave the farms and do other things I I
think we demonize technology when
technology has been the one currency
that has advanced Society for over 200
years so yes I think there should be
less worried that it's going to take my
job because if it's if AI is going to
take your job you were a commodity to
begin with
you can evolve
right you for 10 years I've been hearing
from people like self-driving cars are
going to take away drivers I'm like
great they've had 20 years to think
about this they can do other things yeah
humans are powerful we need to start
under we need to stop underestimating
human beings yes yes okay and for the
just for the finally just to wrap up
thank you
[Applause]
I mean really I really appreciate that
because look what's happened here in
Seven Ten Years human beings are
remarkably capable and so that is the
pillar I will stand on okay and just
some final words from you reaching kind
of in your own industry and your own
world where do you see the the future of
Esports going
it's just grown and growing like I said
from a sports world
is kind of the next best thing if you
are not able to make it to that
professional level obviously you can
play in your local leagues and stuff but
if you wanna
be with your friends and you can become
and make a lot of money from Esports it
is the next best thing to be in a
professional football player being a
athlete being a NFL player you can play
these games in a professional
environment online and it literally is
the then Express thing and and I think
now with virtual reality as well you're
able to
get even better graphics 3D you're
really involved with it so yeah it's
it's a it's a space that's really grown
in terms of from a sports point of view
um arguably is the best next best thing
in terms of golf you can play on a
simulator you can play with your friends
they're doing
um something now called tgl where
they're going to have like an indoor
golf
um league so
there's a massive space in sports for
for Esports and it literally is the next
best thing and I know for me growing up
everyone but guys and girls wanted to be
a footballer you know and it's it's a
window opportunity that not many get to
go through so this is a really nice way
for people to feel included it's kind of
opening up the realm of inclusivity so
it's really good to hear from you about
that Michael your views on the future of
Hollywood and gaming and how they're
going to merge and Collide and you know
you're kind of leading the charge there
well I don't know if I'm leading the
charge but um I'm just adding to it but
uh
you know my 30 000 foot view of uh just
gaming is like you you get to be your
own hero you get to be your own person
saving the world you get to be your own
team
um which is a great wish fulfillment
thing in the world yeah yeah and Gary
what about you the world of the future
of web free gaming Esports what are your
final views what would you like to see
happen in the future I think the
majority of the people in this room and
consuming this content right now are
aware that gaming has now crossed over
into one of the cultural pillars of our
society like movies like sports like
fashion you know for me this is the
smallest on this day as we sit here this
is the smallest that the gaming industry
will be going forward this will continue
to grow it is a pillar of our society
it's ingrained in the fabric it is
something we will do forever it's
something we've always done board games
trading you know cards it's something
we've always done this is the next
scaled Evolution and I think we're uh
we've got very prosperous decades ahead
of us yes so in a nutshell watch this
space and that brings us the end of our
discussion I want to give a massive
Round of Applause please join me to
Gareth Gary and Michael thank you so
much
[Music]
foreign